Tyler's in Pennsylvania hi Tyler welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show how they even
can how are you guys right how can we
help so another question I won about
800,000 on a game show
don't drop by that you did not come on
no I'm a big game show guy which one was
it can you tell us I'll say it's on NBC
that doesn't help me all right
okay we get it wait a co 8 hundred grand
yeah yeah inkay
so we'll be receiving a check in about
four three to four weeks nice so it's
gonna be about probably about 500,000
after taxes and as you can imagine I was
just some advice on how much the gift to
family and then how much you spend on a
house we're about to start babysat for
so I don't know if that changes anything
but yeah the first thing you need to do
is double check triple check your tax
advice because the last my last memory
of this subject might be a few years old
but I think there's a special tax rate
that's extra high for game show winnings
there are it's a my accountant said it
would probably be about close to 475 but
I guess until we get more information on
how its tax that's the figure I was
given four hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars after taxes yeah so
they're taking almost half of it
correct god bless the USA yeah okay so
we got four and seventy five thousand
net of your dadgum thieving government
okay
unbelievable and like they did anything
to do this okay that's so helpful
alright so and then your first question
is how much do I give the family well
probably very little to none what does
family need any of this so I went on
with my grandmother and my
the one who applied and it just ended up
that I'm the closest with her and they
had asked if I could go on so I feel
like everyone thinks they're entitled
and we do want to work last thing
generous why are they entitled I think
because well I think my mom thinks that
because any of the other grandkids could
have got picked and I was the one that
got picked I think she feels like they
should have something your mother spends
a lot of time and guilt trips doesn't
she I'm surprised she even said that
she's so it's so unlike her I think she
just feels like I'm gonna be set for
life and there 475 no sense of her life
darling so it's like it's a lot of money
but you're not set for life all right
Dave this is this thing this is messy so
let me make sure I understand so that
your cousin it was your cousin's idea to
sign you up or your grandmother up my
grandmother she's been wanting to go on
so he did the work to sign her up and
then through a situation they had asked
if I could go on he doesn't live around
here so did you have your grandmother
compete together or was it just you yes
oh so you and grandmother both competed
did you each get 800 yeah well okay
grandmother's got hers if she wants to
give some to her grandkids she can yeah
correct yeah sure you got no obligation
here this is a weird family
let grandmother take care of cousin
Eddie and you take care of you okay what
kind of house you want to buy well
expensive is you need to get you a house
yeah you know we are in a house now what
we're outgrowing it and it's probably
worth about 150 the house we had been
looking to buy it was about 320 and we
were disgusted in on whether that was
too much no write a check to pay cash
for it have you getting other debt no
there's they're starting baby step for
our call yeah that's right yeah right
yeah say this is phenomenal yeah you're
100% debt-free house and everything now
if you want to be generous with a little
bit of what's left over give somebody
five grand or something out of this
that's fine but you are not morally
obligated to you are not morally
obligated
do your entitled cousins in other news
Dave I'm gonna sign up for a game show
I'll be right back yeah there's more
than sign left can you got a win so one
things about having a crack production
team is during the commercial break they
send you the clip of the girl and her
grandmother
they went found it winning the 1.67
million and the grandmother and how
sweet she is and it made me feel really
bad for saying her family was weird well
we titled or we we was on scenario tears
run down my face no breakfast I wasn't
gonna tell anybody that since you said
my eyes it really was wiping his eyes
it's not dusty here in the studio at all
and it was really sweet sweet moment but
to be fair you said her mom was spending
too much time worried about where the
money goes grandmother's great she's got
her money your advice is still spot on
but it would really still don't know why
the grandkids are are entitled to our
cousins are entitled to her money that
she's doing but it's a very sweet yeah
story and fantastic can tell the game
show scripted some of it a little bit
but it's still just fabulously done it's
really well it just that you can tell
the spirit of them grandma and me mo and
the and the daughter or the
granddaughter and it's just it's so I
did feel bad for trashing her family but
because they look like they're really
nice people they're very nice I don't
feel bad cuz I I know but I should be
nicer you're just gonna be just trying
to get on the game show you're me that's
all I'm thinking and I must say you
don't even have a meme oh we the first
time David I've ever watched a game show
together so weird things that happen
during the break we're watching mom
showed you last time